Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Io mi chiamo Antonio.
Sono un amante degli insetti,
e da qui nasce la passione
per quello che vorrei diventasse
il mio mestiere, l'apicoltura.
Prima di parlarvi di apicoltura
o di apicoltura urbana nel senso stretto,
vorrei presentarvi le api,
darvi la possibilità
di riconoscerle e distinguerle.
Le api appartengono
al regno degli imenotteri.
All'interno di questo regno
possiamo distinguere due sottoclassi,
la classe dei predatori
e la classe delle prede.
Tra i predatori troviamo le vespe.
Le vespe è facile riconoscerle:
sono glabre, hanno un'armatura,
sono carnivore,
vanno a mangiare sempre il pesce,
o la carne che noi mangiamo,
sulle tavole,
e il più pericoloso
tra le vespe è il calabrone,
ma ognuno di questi insetti si difende,
non attacca mai l'uomo per sfizio.
Tra le prede troviamo le api.
Tra le api ci sono i bombi,
ci sono le api solitarie,
è facile riconoscerle perché sono
sempre più pelose, un po' più tozze.
La più interessante delle api
è l'Apis Mellifera.
È l'unica che l'uomo
alleva per produrre miele.
Le api vivono in un alveare.
All'interno di un alveare c'è una regina,
centinaia di fuchi,
che è la casta maschile,
e migliaia di api operaie.
Nel pieno della stagione,
verso luglio-agosto,
un alveare può raggiungere
fino a 80.000 individui,
questo ci fa pensare
come calabroni e vespe predano le api.
Quindi, le api sono delle prede.
L'importanza delle api non risiede
nella produzione di miele:
potremmo anche fare a meno
del miele; ma delle api no,
perché le api sono importanti
per l'impollinazione.
C'è un'intera famiglia di piante,
le angiosperme,
che ha affidato
la propria riproduzione alle api.
E quindi, grazie a queste api,
le angiosperme e i fiori
si sono riprodotti in tante varietà.
Pensate che tutte queste piante e fiori,
- di solito le angiosperme
sono quelle con i fiori colorati -
di tutti questi fiori,
le api sono responsabili
per l'80% della loro riproduzione.
Anche l'uomo si nutre di queste piante,
e quindi noi ci nutriamo di frutta
come mele, pere, arance,
indossiamo jeans di cotone
che è impollinato dalle api,
mangiamo la carne che va al pascolo,
e il pascolo è riprodotto dalle api.
Per un buon 50% di quello che noi mangiamo
dobbiamo ringraziare le api.
Quindi le api possiamo dire
che sono le garanti della biodiversità,
e sono quelle
che ci aiutano a sopravvivere.
Infatti da un po' di anni a questa parte
rimbalza sempre una frase di Einstein:
non si sa se sia vero,
se l'abbia detto lui, o meno.
Questa frase dice: "Senza le api,
all'uomo restano quattro anni di vita".
A prescindere se l'abbia detto,
o meno, Einstein è una frase vera,
perché senza le api non ci sono i fiori,
non ci sono i frutti,
e quindi non ci sono gli erbivori,
non ci sono i carnivori,
e di conseguenza non c'è l'uomo.
Il problema è che forse abbiamo recepito
un po' troppo tardi questo messaggio,
infatti le api stanno morendo.
Le api, da almeno dieci anni, muoiono,
per cause tuttora sconosciute:
in realtà non sappiamo perfettamente
qual è la causa scatenante della moria,
e c'è una comunità scientifica
che sta cercando di indagare,
ma non perché - 'salviamo le api
per salvare il miele';
no, 'salviamo le api per salvare l'uomo'.
Quindi un'intera comunità
scientifica sta indagando
nei luoghi dove le api vengono applicate,
ovvero la campagna.
Quella che abbiamo sempre pensato essere
l'amica degli apicoltori,
l'amica dell'uomo,
oggi sta diventando una grande nemica.
E infatti noi vediamo che in campagna
c'è la monocoltura,
ormai esiste l'industria alimentare,
non c'è più la bella campagna,
il posto bucolico-
no, perché gli uomini
aumentano sempre di più
e quindi l'agricoltura si industrializza.
La monocoltura
non offre più cibo alle api,
gli agricoltori devono
nutrirle artificialmente.
Quest'agricoltura sopravvive
grazie ai pesticidi,
che sono la prima causa scatenante
della moria delle api.
E poi non basta solo questo:
ci sono i cambiamenti climatici,
l'inquinamento
delle falde acquifere,
tanti problemi che portano
alla moria delle api.
Ma è la stessa apicoltura intensiva
che le sta distruggendo:
a forza di stressarle
per produrre miele,
'Produciamo, produciamo',
le api reagiscono in malo modo.
La fortuna è che ci sono tanti scienziati
che studiano questi problemi,
ma il problema più grande
è che a volte queste ricerche
vengono finanziate dagli stessi fautori
dell'impoverimento del terreno.
Quindi non esiste una verità oggettiva:
ad ora non sappiamo perché le api muoiono,
fatto sta che le api muoiono.
Come stanno reagendo le api?
Ebbene, le api migrano, perché le api
non sono come tutti
gli animali d'allevamento:
sono animali selvatici,
gli apicoltori danno solo uno spazio.
Migrano, e sapete dove vanno?
In città.
Paradossalmente le api
migrano verso la città,
quella che noi abbiamo sempre pensato
essere inquinante,
'Scappiamocene dalla città'
-no, invece le api le hanno scelte,
quindi è importante capire
per quale motivo,
e i motivi anche qui son tanti.
Prima di tutto,
perché la città ha biodiversità,
la città non deve
produrre cibo dalle piante,
quindi le piante ornamentali
arricchiscono la dieta delle api;
il clima mite, l'attenzione delle persone,
e quindi, sempre di più, nascono
progetti di apicoltura urbana.
L'apicoltura urbana è diffusa a New York,
a Londra- dove ci sono 10.000 alveari,
a Hong Kong, a Melbourne, in tutte
le più grandi metropoli del mondo.
E in Italia non esisteva nulla.
Noi siamo stati i primi
a portare avanti questa pratica,
e così abbiamo iniziato anche noi,
con una squadra di amici e volontari,
a raccogliere gli sciami
che arrivavano in città.
Questi sciami arrivano
e si posano sui segnali stradali,
sulle bici, sui cornicioni:
noi andiamo, li prendiamo,
e invece di riportarli in campagna
per evitare che poi ritornino in città,
gli diamo una giusta sistemazione.
Stiamo prendendo accordi
con vari enti, vari stabili,
per poter posizionare le api
direttamente in città.
E quindi abbiamo
realizzato un apiario
all'interno di una casa
di quartiere, nel quartiere Mirafiori.
Noi siamo di Torino,
e in questo quartiere c'è la Fiat.
Sul tetto di queste case di quartiere
ci sono tre alveari,
le api stanno benissimo, tutti contenti,
e non è l'unico apiario
che abbiamo realizzato.
Ne abbiamo creato uno anche in un museo.
Abbiamo chiesto a Emmanuel Louisgrand,
che è l'autore di questa opera,
che si chiama 'La folie' e rappresenta
un giardino ottocentesco,
se potevamo mettere le api lì dentro,
e lui è stato contentissimo
perché è un museo di arte contemporanea
ed è molto focalizzato
sui temi ambientali,
e quindi ha detto,
mettere le api in quest'opera
può essere un completamento.
E noi l'abbiamo fatto.
Ci siamo spinti oltre:
abbiamo installato anche
un apiario urbano su un balcone,
esattamente sul balcone di casa mia.
Io abito a Torino, in pieno centro,
in un condominio signorile,
quarto piano,
e ci sono tre alveari.
I vicini si sono lamentati all'inizio,
poi hanno scoperto
che le api vanno sui fiori
e che non interessa l'uomo alle api,
quindi, le api, pensate, escono dal nido
e vanno in linea retta sul fiore,
quindi non causo
nessun problema ai vicini,
anzi, ci procura
un po' di cibo, un po' di miele,
e quindi, è perfetto.
Abbiamo realizzato circa
sei apiari a Torino,
ne sono stati realizzati altri
e ne realizzeremo ancora altri,
da pubblici e privati cittadini.
Diciamo che la città di Torino
ha reagito positivamente
alla proposta e alla possibilità
di allevare le api
come hobby, come passione.
Ogni cittadino può allevarle
per dare un rifugio alternativo alle api,
per procurarci del miele,
autoprodurci del miele
e per impollinare le piante della città,
perché senza le api
le piante non si impollinano.
E così noi abbiamo visto le api
non solo come produttrici di miele,
perché attenzione:
le vera importanza delle api
non è nella produzione di miele,
e quindi, siccome in città
si riparte da zero, abbiamo pensato:
perché non utilizzare
le api come bioindicatori?
E allora nasce il Progetto Urbees,
nasce il valore aggiunto
rispetto a tutti gli altri progetti
di apicoltura urbana nel mondo.
Se guardiamo un alveare, un alveare
ha in media circa 50.000 api.
Di queste 50.000, 10.000
sono le raccoglitrici,
ognuna di queste raccoglitrici si sposta
di circa 1,5-2 km dall'alveare,
occupando un'area
di sette chilometri quadri.
Ognuna di queste api
visita circa mille fiori al giorno,
quindi voi pensate,
se noi guardiamo un alveare
come una centralina ambientale
che ci da un'indicazione sull'ambiente,
questa centralina effettua dieci milioni
di microprelievi in ambiente.
Non c'è nessuna tecnologia capace
di fare una cosa del genere
e di stoccare tutte queste
informazioni nell'alveare.
Da queste informazioni
stiamo sviluppando due filoni di ricerca.
Il primo filone riguarda la biodiversità.
Grazie all'analisi sul miele e sul polline
noi possiamo scoprire
quali sono le piante della città,
creare un atlante botanico,
e capire un po' come fare
a mettere delle piante
favorevoli alla vita
di questi imenotteri,
perché è inutile piantare delle piante
che sono belle, e solo estetiche:
no, le piante in città,
la vegetazione urbana,
deve essere funzionale alla natura;
altrimenti è un prato inglese,
che non serve quasi a nulla
se non alla bellezza.
Il secondo filone di ricerca
è l'inquinamento.
Quindi le api ci possono dare informazioni
anche sull'inquinamento,
analizzando i componenti dell'alveare,
le api stesse che volano,
il miele, la cera, il polline, la propoli,
possiamo scoprire in che quantità
e di che qualità,
è l'ambiente e gli inquinanti,
quindi possiamo scoprire
quali metalli pesanti ci sono,
come piombo, nichel, cromo,
radionuclidi, pesticidi, idrocarburi.
Quindi le api integrano gli studi
che vengono effettuati oggi
per studiare la qualità ambientale.
E lo fanno le api, lo può fare
anche qualsiasi cittadino,
quindi non deleghiamo più
il biomonitoraggio
e l'attenzione dell'ambiente ad altri,
possiamo farlo noi stessi,
e così stiamo dimostrando,
nel nostro piccolo,
che si possono avere le api in città,
non bisogna essere per forza
apicoltori professionisti per averle,
e contribuire al benessere
sociale della città.
Così dal 2012-2013-2014,
abbiamo iniziato a raccogliere
dei campioni,
Urbees non ha finanziamenti,
si autofinanzia,
quindi abbiamo iniziato a raccogliere
dei campioni di miele
e analizzarli, per scoprire
se erano commestibili,
quindi iniziamo a capire se il miele
può essere distribuito o meno.
Per nostra grande fortuna, e sorpresa,
abbiamo scoperto che i mieli
urbani non sono inquinati:
sebbene Torino sia una città
molto inquinata,
le api sono capaci
di filtrare l'inquinamento
e di dare al prodotto miele
una grande qualità.
E quindi abbiamo raccolto mieli
nel 2012-'13 e '14,
abbiamo iniziato a distribuirli,
e abbiamo creato
la nostra linea di prodotto.
Prima di pensare al miele come nutrimento,
noi vediamo il miele
come veicolo di informazione,
e quindi all'interno dell'etichetta
abbiamo installato un qr code,
tramite il quale il consumatore
può collegarsi a un sito Internet
e scoprire la qualità dell'ambiente
e le caratteristiche del miele.
Quindi il miele diventa un libro,
un qualcosa da leggere:
tutti possono informarsi
sulla qualità ambientale,
non bisogna per forza
essere produttori di miele
o consumatori di miele:
c'è un sito, si va nel sito,
e si scopre qual è la qualità della vita
all'interno del quartiere in cui si vive.
Solo alla fine di questo processo,
il miele finalmente si può mangiare.
Noi ci siamo divertiti
a dare nomi strani ai mieli,
visto che in città
si fanno solo millefiori
e noi vogliamo fare solo millefiori,
abbiamo dato il nome ai mieli
a seconda del luogo di raccolta,
quindi esiste il miele Antonio,
che è il miele fatto sul mio balcone,
esiste il miele Elvira,
fatto nell'orto urbano di Elvira,
esiste il miele Pav, e il Pav è il museo,
il miele Bunker, che è un'altra realtà
in cui abbiamo le api,
e il miele Andrea, perché Andrea
è un altro apicoltore
che ci sta sostenendo,
abbiamo messo delle api a casa sua
e abbiamo creato il miele Andrea.
Quindi, ognuno può personalizzare i mieli,
cioè, possiamo inventarci
l'apicoltura urbana.
Dandole però un'etica sociale,
non solo per produrre il proprio miele,
ma per dare un contributo alla città.
E quindi, che cos'è, in estrema sintesi,
il progetto Urbees?
Noi raccogliamo gli sciami della città,
li mettiamo nelle arnie,
gli diamo una giusta sistemazione,
diamo la possibilità alle api
di andare a raccogliere
tutte queste informazioni
per raccogliere nettare,
polline, propoli, eccetera;
analizziamo queste matrici,
queste risorse,
e invasettiamo tutto in un barattolo
che contiene sia un'informazione
che un nutrimento.
Ci autofinanziamo la ricerca
grazie alla distribuzione del miele,
i cittadini che mangiano il miele urbano
mangiano un pezzo di città,
assaggiano la città,
perché così il miele
è la sintesi di un luogo:
non è come il vino, o l'olio,
che vengono fuori da una frutta,
vanno a prendere tanti pezzetti
e creano il miele.
E da qui possono nascere tante iniziative:
noi vogliamo dimostrare che tutti
possono fare apicoltura,
tutti possono salvaguardare le api,
e possono dare
un senso diverso alla città.
Quindi, se vogliamo costruire
città sostenibili,
possiamo partire anche dalle api.
Quindi anziché fare città a misura d'uomo
noi vorremmo costruire città
a misura d'ape
dove l'ape è il testimone
della sostenibilità ecologica della città.
Grazie.
(applausi)